in hawkins hauntings and possessed
people start showing up again as eleven
tries to get her powers back and we meet
a new villain who hides a terrifying
past today on cinema recapped i'll show
you stranger things season four and its
big reveal
spoilers ahead
watch out and take care episode 1
this fourth season begins with memory of
the year 1979
in the laboratories where 11 used to
live
in this place a man named dr martin is
studying a boy named ten while many
strange things happen outside
the doctor goes out and realizes that
there are many unlived people everywhere
and finds eleven out of control
in the present we see eleven adjusting
to her new life living with will
jonathan and joyce
eleven is excited to see mike again who
has also grown a lot
on the other hand there's dustin who
still has his girlfriend in a distance
together they hack his school to change
his grades
in another scene we see steve who
continues his good friendship with robin
then the problems begin since lucas has
a basketball game but that same day
there will be a d session with his
friends
at the same time a girl named chrissy
sees strange things in the bathroom
dustin and mike speak to the leader of
the d d club named eddie to ask to
postpone the game and wait for lucas but
it doesn't want to
on the other hand joyce receives a rare
doll and freaks out because it comes
from russia chrissy goes to the forest
and continues to see strange things
she runs in daddy who invites her to go
with him to calm down at the same time
in the other city eleven is sad because
things don't go well and her classmates
bully her returning to joyce she finds a
letter inside the doll which says that
hopper is alive
meanwhile the boys replaced lucas with
his sister erica and we see how both
siblings become the heroes of the two
games
at the same time chrissy suffers for
more hallucinations at eddie's house
he tries to wake her up but then she
sees a horrible monster who unlives her
without compassion episode two
we see a flashback of hopper at the end
of season three who survives after the
explosion but he's captured by the
russians
returning to the present mike travels to
visit 11.
at the same time in hawkins the police
investigate what happened to chrissy
later everyone finds out from the news
about chrissy
joyce talks to murray about the letter
but he doesn't think it's possible that
hopper is alive although he'll still
support her
also eleven and mike have a great time
as they hadn't seen each other in a
while after they moved in at the end of
season three however eleven's classmates
played dirty jokes on her in front of
mike the girl gets very upset
meanwhile joyce investigates and
communicates with an unknown russian who
tells her that she gives him forty
thousand dollars he will release hopper
dustin and some others try to find eddie
to find out what happened to chrissy
while the group of basketball players
also wants to find the boy
but to avenge the young woman since they
think that he was the one who unlived
her
nancy and a friend named fred also
investigate what happened to write about
it
but the boy begins to see strange things
just like chrissy did returning to 11 we
see that she is sad and out of revenge
she hits one of her bullies while she
has memories of the doctor since
apparently she had lost control of her
actions of the past
dustin and the others find eddie who
tells them what he saw
at the same time fred is trapped in
another illusion and the monster unlives
him while the boys deduce from all that
happened that the monster is some kind
of sorcerer
they name him vechna like a d d
character episode three
a special agent from the united states
is investigating with former employees
of the hawkins laboratories
how to find eleven
since he believes that she could be
involved in everything that happens the
next day they find fred so they have two
cases now while the boys try to find
answers in a way to prevent his
innocence
meanwhile mike and levin have some
problems because the girl does not fit
into society the police arrest 11 since
the girl she hit ended up in the
hospital
at the same time joyce and murray go to
alaska to pay for hopper's ransom while
we see that the russians make him work
hard and that one of the guards is the
one who will help him in exchange for
the cash vec now tries to make a
connection with someone apparently one
of the basketball players and we see
that the group of athletes is crazily
hitting others to find clues about eddie
lucas does not know what to do since
eddie is also his friend meanwhile some
men save 11 from the police men who are
ex-personnel from hawking's laboratories
a man named sam tells her the talking is
in danger again and that she's the only
one who can save the city although she
tells him that her powers are gone
however he tells her that he can bring
them back to her but she needs to go
with him
at the same time max also begins to have
visions with vechna episode four
when max comes back to reality she tells
everyone what she saw so they assume
that vecna takes advantage of people's
traumas
then they meet with lucas who warns them
about the basketball players
elsewhere joyce and murray meet with the
contact between them and the russian
guard and give him the promised money
while hopper manages to escape with the
guard's help returning to max she leaves
some goodbye letters in case things go
wrong as she continues to see vecna who
tells her that her time is running out
hopper and the others are betrayed by
the contact since he wants to keep
joyce's money and also get paid for the
location of hopper and the corrupt guard
he also captures joyce and murray since
the russians will pay him a lot of money
for them as well
nancy and robin visit victor a man who
encountered vechna 30 years ago and
although he survived he tells them the
story of how he lost his whole family
first the wife and then both his
children
but when vekno was about to unlive him
as well he heard a song on the radio and
the music made him come back to reality
before it was too late but then the man
gets upset and stops talking meanwhile
max begins to have hallucinations with
her brother billy who went to heaven
last season and then sees vechna who
tells her that it's time to leave
returning to nancy and robin they
deduced that music could be the key to
get people out of illusions
they let dustin know while max sees
vechna's world where she sees strange
things everywhere at that moment the
boys play her favorite music and when
becnu is about to unlive her she
remembers good times with her friends
she gets rid of vecna and runs toward an
exit open by the music
episode 5
11 arrives at the new hawking
laboratories where sam promises her that
she will recover her powers with the
help of a new project called nina used
to recover memories but then she sees
that dr martin is also there so she
thinks that it's all a trick and they
only want to use her just as before
so she runs away although they catch her
pretty quickly then the basketball
player begins to see hallucinations so
his hour approaches returning with
dustin and the others they go to
victor's house which looks very bad
they enter and see that there's an old
clock that everyone sees in their
hallucinations at the same time we see
that the doctor has 11 in a trance state
and that's why she sees herself as
before might will jonathan and another
boy are trying to find eleven
meanwhile joyce and murray managed to
get rid of the man who betrayed them but
since they're mid-flight they make an
emergency landing returning with dustin
and the others they are following a
light signal that is in the house so
they reach a part where there is a very
strong connection with vector since he's
consuming the basketball player in a
lake and destroys the boy's lamps at the
same time eleven tries to escape again
and when the guards catch up with her
she gets rid of them by using her powers
for a woman
she goes back to the doctor to help her
get them back completely episode 6
the doctor explains to 11 that she needs
to enter many of her memories so that
she can awaken her abilities
will and the others go with dustin's
girlfriend to ask her for help to hack
11's location
at the same time hoppers put in a cell
near to a demogorgon the kind of monster
they beat in season one and we see that
the russians are feeding it with men so
hopper tells the other captives that
it's not easy to beat one of these
creatures returning to eleven's memories
she is with a group of children who are
being made to compete to see who best
masters their skills
eleven shows them how strong she is by
defeating the most skilled of all on the
other hand joyce and murray get close to
where hopper is so they use the
traitor's identity to fool the russians
meanwhile hopper and his cellmates
prepare to defeat the demogorgon by
using fire dustin and the others follow
the direction of a compass and make it
to a lake where they think there might
be a portal left by vecna
returning to eleven she is scared by her
companions and the memories she
discovers that apparently she unlived
everyone in the past and didn't remember
it
returning to nancy and her group they
find a strong signal coming from the
bottom of the lake and steve goes in the
water to investigate thanks to this the
boy finds a portal and tells the others
about it but something pulls him down
and takes him to the other world
his friends come after him to help but
we see that he's already being bitten by
creatures in the other world
episode 7 and finale
steve's friends come to the rescue
getting rid of all the creatures
although they see in the distance that
many more are coming
they decide to hide in a nearby forest
since it is difficult for them to return
by the portal while it is guarded by a
lot of creatures
meanwhile eleven is very scared the
process of returning her powers is
taking too long joyce and murray
infiltrate the base where they have
hopper and look for a way to get him out
dustin lucas and erica are caught by the
police and locked up in one of their
houses while they deduce that every time
vechna enlives someone a portal is
created in the crime scene later nancy
and the others manage to establish
communication with dustin and the others
at the same time hopper and his
cellmates are about to face the monster
while being watched by the guards and
his infiltrated friends going back to
dustin they create a clever form of
communication
they tell nancy and the others about the
different portals created by vechna
returning to hopper he's about to start
the battle with the monster who quickly
kills many of them
joyce and murray then quickly knock out
the guards open the doors and save
hopper we see them reunited at the same
time the teens find another portal in
eddie's house while eleven remembers
that in the past a young man helped her
finding out that he was number one then
eleven finds out that she wasn't the one
who enlived all the other boys but one
nancy is teleported away by vechna and
she finds out that one of victor's
children wasn't done live by vekna
either but rather became number one
in the past one told 11 that he began to
discover they had powers in his parents
house and he got rid of them because he
didn't want to be ratted out
while his father never knew the truth so
he left him alive to be blamed for
everything consequently eleven hits him
and both begin a battle of mental powers
but one is very strong and levitates her
to unlive her like the others however
eleven sees good happy memories and she
gains strength and subdues her opponent
and she does it with so much energy that
she opens a portal and sends into the
other world where little by little we
see how he became a monster which in the
present we know is vecna
end of volume one make sure to subscribe
and turn on notifications to watch more
videos like this
thanks for watching